you've even run TV commercials
explaining the program and explain
that's a very unique thing by the way
have you seen two TV commercials and
your jurisdictions on some new
innovative government program private
partnership laws allow projects across a
broad swath of infrastructure classes
here including toll roads schools energy
waste water water solid waste ports
information technology and more in
what's unique about it is most states
have started in the transportation
sector and stayed there for a long time
and haven't branched out yet beyond that
into other sectors of infrastructure and
Puerto Rico's already launched its
program with a much more broad scope it
also established something called the
public-private partnership Authority and
that's a new center of excellence within
the the government here to evaluate and
select these public-private partnership
infrastructure projects and to monitor
and enforce the terms of those contracts
and in just two short years since
they've been in operation the authority
I would say is built a world-class
program and has already seen some major
successes and we're going to talk about
some of those today just for quick
examples as an intro to moderate tell
modernized K through 12 school
facilities and improve their academic
performance the PPP Authority in Puerto
Rico has launched these schools for the
21st century initiative under which
pretty Rico is modernizing and working
with private contractors to modernize a
design build and maintain approximately
100 schools across Berto Rico they've
also in earlier to me in June of last
year they selected the winning bidder
for a 40 year one over a billion dollar
concession for 42 of their toll road
facilities they've also launched a
procurement more recently for a
long-term lease of the San Juan
International Airport which most of you
probably flew into and last week the
authority announced that it's going to
be in seeking private partners to
finance build and maintain a new 600 bed
juvenile treatment center on now those
of us interested in advancing free minds
of free markets we often lament that
there are often many more ideas for
government reform
than public officials actually
implementing them so it's really always
an enriching and reaffirming experience
to discover innovative leaders
proactively taking market-based
solutions from concept to implementation
so we are thrilled to have one of those
leaders with us today someone who's been
very critical to Puerto Rico success and
building their infrastructure program
into what has become a world-class
infrastructure program so without
further ado it's my honor and privilege
to introduce you to our special guests
for this session David Alvarez David
Alvarez thank you thank you and thank
you everyone just by way of introduction
David is the executive director of the
Puerto Rico public-private partnerships
Authority he runs the program that that
I just described prior to his
appointment at the authority he served a
senior adviser and special aide to the
chairman and president of the government
development bank for Puerto Rico and his
chief analyst at santander securities in
santander bank or Puerto Rico he has a
master of science in Urban and Regional
Planning from Florida State and a
bachelor's degree in economics from West
Virginia University so please join me in
welcoming David thank you once again
thank you thank you David so as i
described over the last two years pretty
Rico's has significantly shifted its
approach to infrastructure development
by embracing public-private partnerships
as a major component of your strategy to
fill your funding gap into to solve some
of your problems can you describe the
fiscal and economic factors that led to
the development of your public-private
partnership sure let me start by again
this person my gratitude for the
invitation I think this is very exciting
to be here with you just sharing our
experience I think we have under the
leadership of our governor we have made
substantial progress in renovating
infrastructure in Puerto Rico and the
idea that there's a role for the private
sector in infrastructure that at the end
of the day what we're looking for is to
bring fresh capital for fresh investment
into the economy create jobs and look
for innovation in the delivery of public
services in many of the infrastructure a
lot of the all this is started with
obviously with a clear need to to bring
this about and let me just tell you what
the the background is just responding to
your to your question land this is the
rate of investment that we were having
in the infrastructure in Puerto Rico
what were you what you see in here is a
10 years of history of the percentage of
our gdp dedicated to infrastructure and
obviously in the decade in between 1990s
and 2000's investing around four percent
of our gdp in infrastructure and one one
element that contributed to to having
such a high level of just a normal level
of investment infrastructure was that it
was complemented public investment in
infrastructure was complemented with
private participation in the decade
between the 1990s and the two thousand
we have a couple of code generators of
electricity funded fully funded by
infrastructure private prisons actually
and private investment was complimenting
the entire public effort and investment
without crowding it without replacing it
but just providing an additional flux
into investment everything was abandoned
after the two thousand and this is what
you have and this is from four percent
we're back into in 2009 we experienced
at just one point six percent which is
half of what nations and what the US is
actually invest in infrastructure in
general terms at healthy or at least the
minimum level of investment
infrastructure should be around three
percent or three point five percent of
GDP and this is what we have so this
coincided when you have such a high
level of in the investment
infrastructure we were growing at a
three percent in real terms of the
economy now we were contracting four
percent so we had a very deep recession
obviously that coincided with this level
of investment so one of the reasons that
we wanted to make sure that we bring
capital to infrastructure is to restore
this level of investment infrastructure
we were suffering from this decline let
me just show you another slide or yeah
so just do what are the reasons that
again was such a level low
infrastructure that public pool the
government cannot needed to look for
partners private partners is obviously
that we were facing a tremendous deficit
we inherited a deficit that was
forty-four percent of our government
revenues and here you can see it I mean
it's very clear the revenues of the
government where we came in they were
the general fund which is the budget of
the central government we're around six
seven point six billion dollars but the
government was actually spending 3.3
billion dollars on top of that so there
was no way that we were going to restore
investment and infrastructure with this
high level deficit we experienced one of
the highest if not the highest deficit
in the in the nation and it was very
limit in fact we needed to go out and
look for private investment there was no
other other choice so the general
approach for us and terms of ppps the
way we see this and we approach it is
that we look at infrastructure and that
in a different way that you had
different tools there's a toolbox for
investing in infrastructure obviously
you have your typical things a gorman
has your typical things there public
bonds their taxes taxation we just
included a new tool for doing that which
is public-private partnership which is a
systematic way of bringing private
investment into public infrastructure
and with the legislation for that we
approve legislation in 2009 and the that
established a clear policy framework in
which we will promote investment a
private investment or private
participation in public infrastructure
across all infrastructure we can do toll
roads we can do schools we can do
for sports different things even waste
management facilities elderly housing we
can do a lot of things correctional
facilities as long as they are conducted
under the legislation on the bird
transparent basis in a very systematic
way so also the legislation created the
public-private partnerships Authority
which is the entity that I that I lead
and which has allowed us to create a
consolidated framework and having
consistency across all infrastructure
projects so this is kind of the
background in which we created all the
all the projects that we have done in
all the efforts and it's being very
successful tuna so one of the
interesting aspects of your program is
that you do have a centralized structure
for decision-making you have this PPP
Authority who is the I call it a center
of excellence but it's you're really the
driver for the entire proto Rico
government for PPP projects and that's a
pretty unique approach in the u.s. at
least around the world that's a very
common approach for delivering privately
financed infrastructure but in the u.s.
we that's one of the things that's one
of the best practices at Adrian a Bob
and I are constantly talking about to
policymakers in the US which is you
actually can get more of these types of
projects done if you have a vehicle that
is set up to do that right as opposed to
giving existing agencies the
responsibility of figuring out how to
use a new and complex tool so can we
just switch gears for a second and to
talk about the authority and the work
that you do you know can you describe
the role of the PPP authority more you
know more in more depth and what
benefits have you seen from having that
centralized approach as opposed to
having individual agencies out there
trying to pursue these projects without
experience doing it themselves sure I
think that you describe it correctly we
are a center effects on is one of the
most important things is having
consistency across all the projects when
you have different government agencies
trying to run different procurement
processes
it just becomes our extended all the
different agencies had different
approaches to different projects
investors to start running around going
through one two three four or five
different agencies just for one project
there are not they find themselves lost
I mean that's not the way to attract
private investment that's not the way we
want to bring fresh capital into the
economy and create jobs so it becomes a
very cumbersome process very
bureaucratic very specific very
frustrating sometimes we have
consolidated all that into this agency
they had to go just one place for
particular projects we don't run all the
projects is difficult to be in a new
government agency we cannot run all the
sudden hundred projects so we had taken
it a one one project at a time type of
approach so at the same time you have
consistency across transparency we are
we use our website and a great deal and
again when you go back to the
traditional model not all the government
agencies are transparent in the very
same degree they bury some of them are
not transparent or also are just
slightly transparent in their processes
so we have contributed to consolidating
the processes be more transparent even
communicating to the public more
effective more effectively that that has
gone a long way we just do it we come
with the d-o-t secretary will put
together a round table in just one
message one project so it's very
organized and that has helped a great
deal in maximizing the way we do
projects and procurement in Puerto Rico
well let's talk about some of the
projects this is always the fun part for
me is getting into the weeds of the
actual
this is where this is where the theory
and all the things that we write about
in our policy shop actually come into
play in real life so this is always the
fun part so let's start with your
Schools Initiative because I find this
to be one of the more fascinating
aspects most states that have shifted
into public private partnerships as i
mentioned have started with
transportation that's sort of the
leading edge so to speak of the private
infrastructure market we've all heard
about it bob has been writing about you
know that kind of model for years and
years and it's happening out there all
over the place what's now emerging are
is the use of that same type of tool
elsewhere and I've always thought that
k-12 schools would be a perfect
application for public partnerships
they're always have money in the
facilitators you know I mean it's great
there's a lot of opportunity there i
think that when the education
establishment figures out that this
finance tool is out there i think we'll
start to see more of it and i think once
you start to see projects like this one
will see more of it so can you can you
talk about the schools for the 21st
century initiative tell us where you
were where you starting from what the
goals were and how you how you're
getting there sure this is one of the
first projects that we generated under
the p3 authority this the way we call it
actually we started from mmm for a very
clear need for investment where you can
see here is samples of six different
public schools in Puerto Rico by the way
we have a very extended large pulley
school system in Puerto Rico Puerto Rico
has 1400 over 1,400 schools and we have
schools of all sizes and shapes is
incredible we have even schools that are
from 300 students all the way to the
thousand students we even have schools
that have 25 students I mean it is the
clear example of government being
overextended because we build schools
for every community so the maintenance
of the infrastructure is a real
challenge in Puerto Rico and government
funds with the deficit that we have and
these car discours scarcity or resources
obviously maintenance is something that
is being very
a big challenge for government so this
is some of the conditions of the
infrastructure that you can see in some
of these schools i mean the oldest
schools that you're seeing here were
selected to be modernized and obviously
organized with the collaboration of the
private sector will tell you a little
bit more about each but you can we were
we look for even examples where the
students were put at risk with
conditions that were not in a tropical
climate like puerto rico having outside
for outdoor furniture it doesn't work it
just uh it shouldn't happen right the
student should be able to go out and
have fun play and do some learning
activity so there are all kinds of good
so there was a clear need for investment
in public schools this is what we did we
the government look for ways to finance
better modernization of 16 police cause
we did not want to rebuild or build new
schools really we want to take care of
this actual stock of schools we need we
do not need more schools we need better
schools so we team up with the private
sector in order to put together a
program which is private sector will
design build and do the maintenance of
this school the funding was a public
source funding that was very very
favorable in terms of course it was very
cheap capital so we decided to put some
public funds together with innovation
and construction design and maintenance
of the private sector we created a
platform there where we're going to
deliver faster and delivering savings
for the government and will transform
hundred public schools and all this
created very wide support for public
perry punishes the first time in puerto
rico that we take a serious step and
integrating the private sector into the
infrastructure of the education system
before both these steps besides being
publicly financed all these steps work
growth where government
steps with traditional procurement will
do Gorman will do the whole design you
actually will do one hundred percent
design the school will have to be
designed fully before you actually build
it and then a maintenance will be also
gorman in this in this 100 schools all
this is transferred to the public to the
private sector and the results are
incredible i mean it has allow for
faster delivery of modernization schools
jobs are being created and investment is
happening in schools obviously we went
through all the throughout the headaches
of moving students to other schools and
all that but people are getting involved
their jobs are being created and
investment is is quickly moving into the
economy to different schools in
different municipalities across federico
so a very interesting project that is
having a substantial impact in the
economy and this is what we want private
embed of partnering with the private
sector to create and faster delivery
better better projects and create jobs
okay so now let's move on to the next
project the second PPP project that you
had in your toll roads and last year you
finalized a forty-year billion dollar
lease of the PR 22 and PR five toll
roads can you tell us about this
initiative and what prompted it what
improvements you expect sure similar to
similar but different approach this this
one is fully financed this is a picture
of the toll road that we call p re 22 is
the largest and the bcs toll road in
puerto rico actually this is this here
is the largest toll plaza in puerto rico
very very congested at need of a lot of
public were a public investment and very
difficult to maintain under the fiscal
constraints that we had so we decided to
team up with the point with the private
sector in which we will do a long-term
lease of the audit or oat and a private
sector will come and do all the
investments all the improvements and
operate the toll road for a four year
term
here again just a sample of the
conditions that we were facing you have
even from safety conditions in which the
electric the electrical system or some
of the highway was not functioning
correctly when the guardrails were not
in good shape so those are safety common
conditions you can see how we needed to
restore investment here so we did a
procurement process a PPP procurement in
which we invited the private sector to
come and do a payment for the rights and
for operating the toll road for forty
year concession the total revenue will
flow to the private sector and they
would do and they would do a great
program of public improvements that
would deal with congestion and still the
government will monitor the compliance
of operating standards for detour route
so this way September of last year we
closed a deal after the procurement in
which a consortium composed by goldman
sachs and spanish toll road operator
whose name is albert is they won the
procurement for actually maintaining and
operating PR 22 together with PR 5 which
is a smaller toll road here with just
one topless at their seven toll plaza
across this tour road here which is the
one you saw in the pictures is a 40-year
concession it's a long-term lease it was
successfully closed very good there now
you travel the detour oh now you can see
people work in doing the landscaping
improvements in the lighting and all the
answer people are seen already the
difference of private participation and
investment in public infrastructure is
something that this state they just did
not have government did not have the
resources to conduct in a very fast and
pillaging way I'm just as an aside if
you did not have the PPP approach for
this project how long would it take
government oh no that there were no
there were no resources in the highway
and transportation authority to do this
there was besides not having the
resources to do the investment needed to
restore pavement conditions which are
better for drivers or even safety
conditions there was no resources to do
that even they were confronting problems
with managing correctly the top classes
were we were experiencing revenue
leakage I mean they were not actually
there was there was an estimated amount
of revenue leakage there so I mean not
only the physical improvements also the
operational administrative managerial
part was not was not at these standards
that we wanted to so I mean we put it
out there all in the contract we're very
clear and making sure we want to require
work class operating standards for the
toll roads and now the Transportation
Authority what they do is just manage
that that is being in compliance to it
and it's being is working very nicely so
far yes so no a lot of time a lot of
resources that we did not have we're not
going to spec to have a world-class
infrastructure that we going to have
very soon it will take very very long if
we are going to Everett to experience
that very long as ever yeah right been
cut okay so let's shift to the third the
third PPP project you're actively
currently pursuing a long-term
concession for this m1 airport so tell
us about the goals there and what are
you trying to ensure very similar to the
tour wrote you all been here this is the
largest airport in the Caribbean and it
has the largest market share of seats
travelers into the Caribbean region
again there's there's need for
investment here is being managed by the
Port Authority who has a very
deteriorated credit profile at this
point they they cannot even issue bonds
anymore they're not in the public market
and the info
butchers has deteriorated some this is
just the samples even safety conditions
are not the best and obviously
accommodation for passengers they had to
wait in gates or way to pick up being
pick up by family or friends are not the
best we want to change that and we want
to take an approach in which a private
sector will come in private ambassador
will come in and operate the airport
improve and conduct a series of capital
investments and just apply work work
clas standards and practices to a better
airport we believe that I mean we have
it we've been running it for many years
and it is it is we have what we have
right now but definitely being the
largest airport in the Caribbean we want
to have and deliver a better experience
for the traveler so for us this is not
just a financial transaction it's an
economic measure really we want to
improve and the infrastructure and bring
more passengers to Puerto Rico this is
crucial being an island you want to make
sure the no not only passengers and
individuals can come and with ease into
in and out for pleasure of your business
into Puerto Rico but also the
international trade a lot of the forty
six percent of our international trades
by air and ninety percent of that is
handle it at this Airport so want to
make sure that the cargo business is
well run so right now we're about in the
final phase of having a procurement
process for this in which the private
sector will take the risk of financing
operating and maintenance and
improvement on improving the airport a
major undertaking I think it will be the
first you us PPP airport in the US we're
very excited about improving this in a
long term basis and delivering a very
experienced for passengers this is what
we're working on I'm fully dedicating
like ninety percent of my time just to
this now but we're in
the final phase of this and and it would
be a great experience to show the rest
of the nation that airports also can
benefit from private investment and were
run and work class standards and we were
fascinated by the fact that having more
passengers into Puerto Rico will be a
great thing for economic development and
again a driver of positive change
creating jobs and better trade with with
the with other parts of the world so
that's that's the general intent there
okay and so what else is coming in the
pipeline what's next sure we are we have
where Perry bc have a pipeline of
working with other like you mentioned we
just launched a private a project for
the private sector to design build
finance and maintain a juvenile
correctional facility we believe that
again the infrastructure part can be
handled better by the private sector a
lot of innovation can be chief there the
correctional facility we have also the
transportation projects we're looking at
new Greenfield extensions of the highway
system which are we're not even
considering issuing bonds so public debt
for that or wasting or not wasting but
having any tax tax money into
transportation that can be well run and
paid by users and financed by private
sector so that's more more
transportation correctional facilities
probably more schools and finishing the
airport that's what we have in the next
eight months for us hit the p3 authority
in Puerto Rico and what would you say
makes Puerto Rico an attractive place
for investment I think that obviously
the approach that we have taken has gone
a long way in providing comfort to the
private sector we're being transparent
we've been very rigorous in the projects
we don't launch a project until we study
it research it and understand and
prepare ourselves to go out
to make sure that the private sector is
no wasting time or resources in getting
into a procurement that is not well
thought out so we're dedicating a lot of
effort to that also we are we're a u.s.
territory we have we r do a US
jurisdiction with all the judicial
system of the u.s. obviously banking
system that is regulated by by all the
federal government agencies and all that
that provides also additional comfort
but I think the approach and the the
fact that Puerto Rico is the vibrant
economy is the largest economy in the
Caribbean we have a very strong consumer
sector very strong manufacturing sector
all those act of those things combined
make us a interesting investment
destination for the private sector okay
so with that I would like to open up the
well first can we give a hand to David
Alvarez please thank you all right and
I'd like to open up to questions okay
wait till I get to you with the oh can
you turn this one on okay hi-c so
obviously the private sector is way
better at operating most of the public
assets and I all these did you say a
thousand schools I said four yeah it's a
1400 schools so there's fourteen hundred
schools and working on and I see that
they're involved in the infrastructure
when are you going to dump all 1400 over
to someone to run them yeah correct best
does the SEC that's the question that we
have the 20 schools for the actually the
schools for the 21st century is being
run and the coroner lost this project I
mean even the communities they they are
very excited about the opportunity of
being extended to other schools we are
working now on extending that to more
than 100 schools at adding another set
of hundred schools maybe Intuit program
so we go little by little to make sure
that that we extend the
program to the to the rest of the
schools again a lot of the schools in
Puerto Rico were built in a different
decade for a different purpose
population was growing at a faster rate
so probably we right now there's a lot
of stock of schools that probably won't
won't be needed in the future so there's
also an exercise that we had to do of
consolidating schools so now we're just
focusing of having rather than having
the quantity of schools being spread
around is more of the quality of schools
so we're probably going to have a second
round of schools for the 27 21st century
program together with some consolidation
that makes sense in reducing the number
of schools yeah that's that's that's
another another whole set of a big
question in Puerto Rico and hopefully
we'll get to that point soon this it is
on our agenda obviously it is it is
contemplated in our p3 legislation and I
think this was a very important first
step people see the difference they see
that private sector can make a
difference in the educational system and
that has been very welcome so hopefully
this will help us get there in many
parts of the United States privatization
public-private partnerships tend to be
politically controversial your program
now is is you know up and running for
several years what's been the political
reaction reaction of media is it a
controversial issue or so far you having
mostly good support from the public and
from legislators and so forth it is a
controversial issue so far I think that
there's a recognition that that the
Gorman has has a chronic deficit that
there's need to think of out of the box
let's say and look for alternatives so
there's a level of recognition there
people will accept it as long as they
they understand it the bully schools was
one where we debated a long time because
people were thinking that we were just
selling the schools or something we
explained that the private sector was
just
at this point building and doing
infrastructure and we even went to the
communities and presented this is your
school now this is how it's going to
look we have an entire team that goes to
the communities they have kind of
grassroots meetings so explaining goes a
long way in the toll road what we did is
the same thing that we're going to do in
the airport we're going to make sure
that the private sector delivers a
difference early in the process making
sure that people will start seeing the
difference within months of awarding the
deal is important because they they want
to see things different they want to see
things that are improving and that has
gone a long way in terms of the toros
deal for the airport we're doing the
same approach I mean in the toros
transaction the private sector has to
invest 75 million dollars in the first
three years of the concession so it's
very up front loaded and the airport
will be the same approach that approach
has gone a long way for us controversies
are there questions that people ask
questions we have together with our
approach we have not being shy and go
out and being open about it and say
listen this is what we're doing because
we believe in this and we're going to
create jobs this way too and you've even
run TV commercials explaining the
program and explain yeah that's a very
unique thing by the way many of you've
seen TV commercials and your
jurisdictions on some new innovative
government program you know these guys
are out there actually trying to
actively communicate not only are they
doing the implementation of the projects
but you're trying to communicate it in a
in a very innovative way that I've not
seen anywhere else in the u.s. yeah we
have dedicated efforts in in even doing
TV commercials I mean we put the schools
I think we put together like three
different TV commercials for the tour
roads we put together for TV for TV
commercials that were different and they
run for some time the airport we had TV
commercials running up to 31st December
last year so yeah we're not we're going
out and explaining what we really want
and what we really want is economic
development again positive change and so
far it's been is
been well received so obviously every
project is is unique the airport might
be seen different the Correctional
Facility seemed different but we even
run focus groups on this on every
project see how the perception of people
are and and we try to tackle that and
put a communication strategy around that
as a function of that so that's
important thank you back here a couple
of questions if I may you had mentioned
that the one of the byproducts one of
the pleasant by-products is the creation
of jobs but of course there's also a
loss of jobs there's a transfer of
workers from public workers to private
workers and i would think one of the
goals would be a net loss of jobs
because you could probably have fewer
workers working more efficiently so what
if you could speak to what happens to
the public workers who would no longer
doing the job that you are being
replaced by private workers and a
totally separate question on the toll
roads there's an issue it seems to me
that on these 40-year toll road
concessions there's a risk that the
concessionaire at the faults and doesn't
perform their job and I was just curious
very briefly got getting too much in the
weeds what kind of financial controls
that you have so that to protect
yourself against the financial downside
of an operator who discovers they did
too low and they're losing money and
they walk from the job sure on the jumps
question that's a very it's a very
important question I mean one of the
reasons we are doing this is because we
won't deprive exactly to grow we have
taken an approach in which we analyze in
detail the number of John of public
public officials and pulley jumps that
are kept by or dedicated to each of
these infrastructures we have the
ability to provide an opportunity really
to public public workers and we tell
them that they can go to the private
side
sir or they can stay within the public
sector that has gone a long way also in
allowing more will receive all the
projects the reality is that people a
lot of people tend to go to the private
sector so you either have some public
officials going to the Pope private
sector and some others decide to stay
and the ones that you decide to stay we
have relocated them in other in other
toll roads or in other parts another
another type of jobs and things like
that but we we keep them some others
have have gone and take advantage of
different retirement windows that we
have opened simultaneously with this so
the primary concessionaires have taken
the public employees and actually they
want to recruit the private the public
employees really and had created if not
all all the public employees had
transferred they had created additional
jobs into into the to make make sure
that they covered the difference now a
lot of the new incremental jobs happen
when you require new investment in the
in the capital improvements I mean jobs
in construction jobs in improving the
total the pavements doing all kinds of
things those are newly created jumps
into the economy that a lot of them work
as a stimulus immediate stimulus for the
economy which helps you again to reach
the jumpstart the economy and get things
moving so yes it's a complicated
equation some public jobs will be
retained in the government but
definitely the ones that are dedicated
to the capital improvements that's all
incremental new jobs into the economy
and these companies that would maximize
the public infrastructure they actually
the tour boat operator ones more traffic
so they will tend to do more
improvements along the
life of the concession and that will be
all private sector new jobs so that's
the approach that we we takin their into
into that the other question was one of
my sure I remember the the the other
question was the one related to was it
the approach of the yeah okay the
default you're right i mean the the
public interest has to be protected one
particular item before before going into
more into detail the public-private
partnership model of deliver and
infrastructure has an operator of the
infrastructure investors will come in
pairs they will come as a team and
usually you get an operator different
structure of the infrastructure and a
financial partner if the operator is
having troubles financially the
financial partner would not put the
concessional risk would not put the
contractor risk and probably they will
take action before they go into the
phone they will replace the operator
with somebody else even the lenders of
the concessionaire so this is the
contract the model itself is robust in
that sense we have we had to write this
the government has the right research
the right to replace the operator and
actually is try to deal with the lenders
or the financial partners if the
operator is about to go default because
that's something that you want to avoid
so we're fully protected that we have
reserved all the rights contract
contract ly speaking we have yourself
all the rights to replace any finance
years or any of the operators in case of
default how far or be it a roadmap for
future projects and health how many
projects and how far into the future
does it go we have a pipeline of
projects that right now we are we're
running to procurements of the airport
which is in the final phase of the
procurement process and we have this new
facility correction a juvenile facility
that we we just want you that it's going
to be a two thousand
12 project after that we're going to
concentrate back in transportation with
some new Greenfield new construction
projects of certain highways including
PR 22 the one that you saw is not it
does not cross as the north of Puerto
Rico fully there's an extension that we
want to complete we have a pipeline of
between two and five projects additional
projects that we want to launch so it
goes well into 2016 right now at this
point and again we taken one project at
a time we want to make sure that at the
beginning of the program we got it right
we were not trying to do all projects at
once so it's important that from the
schools we learn we applying things from
the toll roads we learn we applying to
insert the future and the toll road
again I mean into in the pipeline again
it goes well you again next three or
four years of new projects coming into
the pipeline based on a lot of the
experience that we have built early in
the process thank you so much thank you
both thank you